tonight on at canada
we're crushing on canadians
i'm very proud of being canadian the
coolest comedians hi how's it going
canada the sexiest singers
about home in canada i miss like tim
hortons and let's not forget the
all-star athletes it's great to be back
then
you won't believe which star is actually
canadian plus
superhero simu that's not going to
happen there is very much a special
meaning to it i mean this is home for me
in every sense of the word and
yeah
we did
reminiscing with keanu uh no i've never
been very good at air guitar
this is et canada crushing on canadians
oh keanu we stand on guard for the and
simul rachel and justin with glowing
hearts we see
the sleigh
you can slay
i don't know if i like that rendition
welcome to a very special and very
patriotic edition of bt canada tonight
we are shining a spotlight on all the
stars that have a swooning for our
country yeah it is gonna get steamy so
let's start things off with canada's
sexiest singers thank you didn't make a
list
i love you canada you're amazing
the biebs
i'm proud on behalf of the country and
on behalf of everybody that supported me
drizzy cohorts and heated floors no
parental guidance i just see the voice
therapy sessions i'm in a waiting room
reading forbes i never would think like
just by releasing some music and posting
videos i could have this much of a
strong of a connection between so many
people mr mendes
[Music]
i wish i had a way to downplay it but
there is no way to downplay this roger
roger cena's 50 000 people and it's huge
and it's going to be spectacular the
toronto trifecta we can't help but crush
hard but while justin is happily married
to haley hi
this is my wife his heart will always be
with his favorite coffee shop what do
you miss most when you're on the road
you know about home in canada i miss
like tim hortons and of course his
monster collaborator shawn mendes
[Music]
with monster with justin bieber i know
he was your idol for so many years what
was it like in being in the recording
studio finally with him super normal at
first and then i think i might have had
two to five minutes of like shock and
pure disbelief
and we were in the same disbelief after
his split with camila cabello and he
can't help singing about it
as for drake well he only has eyes for
his adorable son adonis it's gonna be
much
bigger than me
am i going to be much bigger than you
yeah
but who's bigger than celine
[Applause]
silenzio is
one that i of course like grew up
listening to she's just such an amazing
and powerful vocalist so is it safe to
say that if
celine called you
like tomorrow you would be ready because
you're like it's still in nothing like
you would be ready to go listen i would
have been ready yesterday if she called
tomorrow
but having a killer collab with none
other than john legend isn't too shabby
for now
and what's sexier than a beautiful voice
well a sense of humor of course and
canada's coolest comedians have got us
in stitches
[Music]
i'm very proud of being canadian hi
how's it going canada
she's canada
i've often said
if i wasn't actually canadian i would
want to be canadian we couldn't agree
more mike myers has been making canada
and the rest of the world laugh since
taking us to wayne's world
it's how i used to talk when i was 12
years old until about 15
and
everybody i grew up with in the suburbs
of toronto
as for ryan reynolds he grew up on the
other side of the country but he's just
as funny what makes dwayne the sexiest
man alive honestly it's his
vulnerability he has access to a great
wellspring of his own vulnerability and
i love that about him and that's
something i think is really beautiful i
thought you were gonna do a joke that
i'm sorry i wasn't no you're right
i've let the team down i realized that
i've completely let the team down um yes
the back of his head does look like a
penis
[Music]
we sure do yes it's the best kept secret
one of the most beloved celebs in the
world is a canadian citizen it's true
the rock's dad rocky johnson was born in
amherst nova scotia and he too was a
professional wrestler
is he exciting or is he back in 2009
after the canadian government made
changes to its citizenship rules dwayne
the rock johnson officially can now call
himself a canuck and we're happy to have
him
now to some thriving teens yes it's hard
to believe little jacob trombley is not
so little anymore we've been crushing on
the vancouver native since his first
role in smurfs 2.
since you've been in all these movies
they look to go oh man that guy you must
be like driving lamborghini you must be
like living the high life no not at all
like an artsy lamborghini
as for one of jacob's faves we binge
watch stranger things so good right yeah
it's really good yes just like us he's
totally into the netflix series starring
our next canadian crush ben wolfhart the
show is about a group of friends
and uh one of their friends goes missing
and they vow to try to find him i'll
stay up here in case he tries to
escape yes the show will reportedly end
in season five
but that means more finn on the big
screen the vancouver native recently
wrapped when you finish saving the world
with julianne moore is currently
shooting the legend of ochi with willem
dafoe
now as for finn's fave well it's one of
our own fun fact me and carlos once went
to the same church together his cousin
lives in vancouver and carlos came one
time one more time we're in the same
thing and then we've like met for
stranger things obviously i was like i
well i know you from ytv carlos is a i'm
gonna i'm gonna absolutely take a moment
to go back carlos was like my almost my
entire childhood he hosted this show
called the zone on ytv for like
six or seven years and when i met carlos
i was like totally star stretch and one
more hour of me
that is so adorable carlos is kind of a
big deal around here much like our next
stars the ones that put the super in
superhero in a plate canadian way of
course
yes simu made us all canadians proud
snagging the role of a lifetime as shang
chi and it's written all over his face
so for you to come home here and see
that billboard of you in toronto like
we were seeing this on instagram and it
just must be like a whoa
moment how big of a woman is this for
you there is very much a special meaning
to it i mean this is
home for me in every sense of the word
and his tick-tock game well let's just
say he's got that superpower too
it's just a hologram like a video
game ludi lynn wowed us as zach taylor
in the power rangers reboot my first
action figure was a power ranger before
joining the dc world as merc in aquaman
oh
and mortal kombat yup looty is certified
babe status we know you're always in
shape but this is next level stuff what
kind of a task was it for you to
actually put in that work to bring liu
kang to the screen
to stay in shape for a role like this i
really had to hit the ground running
i'm a superhero
is she ever welcome aman valani to the
universe this is crazy i grew up with
you
dude you were my babysitter my mom would
just like leave ytv on
and it was you the canadian newcomer
debuts as kamala khan marvel's first
on-screen muslim hero it's not really
the brown girls from jersey city to save
the world
that's the fantasy too
and from the big screen to the small
canadians are blazing quite the trail
when it comes to the tube i actually
thought season one was a fluke you
kissed ben gross paxton asked you out on
top of you moving to india wait what's
happening i know it's a lot my tray beat
out 15 000 girls for the coveted role of
davey and never have i ever and was
hand-picked by the executive producer
herself i felt pretty nice i felt pretty
nice it was nice to be funny called
funny by you know mindy kaling who wrote
so many episodes of the office my
favorite tv show so that felt really
nice to hear that and it made me feel
like confident that i do belong in
hollywood hailing from mississauga
ontario could there be a cuter canadian
success story
we've got it bad for you girl
another ontario hometown girl sandra oh
from the country's very own capital of
ottawa i will say i probably one of the
number one words that when people come
up to me and say how much they like this
show they're obsessed yes they're
obsessed and that's always so exciting
that that you're on you're riding the
wave of something that is resonating
with people if you'd really changed
you wouldn't have come here uh if you'd
really changed you wouldn't have let me
sandra's performance in killing eve
certainly didn't kill her career quite
the opposite i'm 47 now
and i just feel come on look
look at this it's great sandra got her
big break landing the role of christina
yang on a little show called grey's
anatomy back in 2005. there are certain
episodes that you know you hit something
right did she ever 220 episodes later
you will walk down the aisle you will
get married you hear me christina we
need this
we need you to get your happy ending
okay i'm ready all right
i think it i'm going to be honest sandra
is one of my favorite actresses she's
such a shining star and i'm just i got a
bit of a crush on her canadian gym
that's for sure yes we're just getting
started we've got a lot more stars from
this soil like the star so big he got
that first name recognition and the
country started going pop star with his
boys and 98 degrees stay with us even if
they invite me into 98 degrees for a day
per day that's all all i need
[Music]
listen all of canada is obsessed with
you so include myself so thank you so
much
i'm obsessed with canada
and we're obsessed with rachel but who
are other notable canucks crushing on
hey uh my hometown hero from the city of
brampton is the metal queen herself lee
aaron
let's go with catherine o'hara
local genius catherine o'hara i was
wondering who you're going to pick
that's easy for me i would say more
again really yeah oh it's going to get
awkward i was gonna say carlos
okay i mean i'm gonna pick carlos too
now no you can't you can't get a good
man
okay i don't even know what to say
anymore so let's take a look at some
legendary canadians i mean i still heart
you i heart you
[Music]
john wick suffering fighting for freedom
keanu is our ultimate crush whether he's
got us on the edge of our seats and john
wick dock five seconds three two
one and away we go
or showing off his comedic talents in
bill and ted yeah
we did
most important question piano have your
air guitar skills improved over the past
three decades uh no i've never been very
good at air guitar but
what i lack in talent i
now i probably don't even make up an
enthusiasm
and who can forget mr eugene levy we are
oh so lucky to call this comedic genius
our own i mean american pie anyone
this is just a bad reception honey oh
baby what's that you know what dirt just
uh give me this and let's get this oh
the hell's the matter with this thing
here and let's not forget a little show
called shit's creek what is your
favorite season
awards speaking of eugene his on-screen
wife katherine o'hara is a canadian hero
all on her own watching catherine work
is is something else and she's just so
gifted and she's so funny and she does
have a very natural charm so pumped
can't you see it in my face it's great i
even dressed up for it imagine
oh that the day did have a slight cigal
test what's she talking about the hiccup
what hiccup who's hiccuping
okay now with so many stars on our
screens we can't forget all those stars
on the stages singing us those sweet
country songs though we definitely have
that country soul in our beautiful and
yes sometimes very cold
[Music]
my head country then you leave tim yeah
we doing more drinking land
fishing gotta be nice
[Music]
and stephen lee olson with nashville or
nothing yes while he may have his eyes
on the american city the toronto native
is canadian through and through what's
one of the jobs that we wouldn't imagine
that you had
working your way to to where you are
today so the last job i had i worked at
a tire shop just turning over tires in
uh in ontario
and it was uh it was one of the most
amazing jobs i've ever had i got to work
with a family
yes mackenzie porter is killing the
country charts collaborating with dustin
lynch for the smash hit thinking about
you everything feels like really new and
fresh and cool
[Music]
and it's got us thinking about the
multi-talented lenin stellar
[Music]
her solo career has taken off and her
debut album 321 is definitely a number
one hit do blondes or brunettes have
more fun i'm feeling this the dark hair
to be honest right now everybody's like
do you miss your blonde hair and i'm
like should i everyone's like everyone
you're making me feel like you're making
me feel like maybe i should yeah i ain't
the same without you
girl you're the one that i need
like flowers near the rain like gas
needs the flame you're the wives
and of course we can't forget our boy
brett kissel who's teaming up with get
this the teenage heartthrob 98 degrees
our temperature is going way up after
this one
you know how a mayor of a city sometimes
will give you the kids to the city for a
day yeah whatever even if they invite me
into 98 degrees for a day for a day
that's all i need
yeah there's something about bread and
98 degrees that just works it's like um
maple syrup and canadian bacon i love
canadian bacon so good much like i love
a mixed martial artist with a great
smile and of course lots of charm you
know i'm talking about george st pierre
and after the break he tells us
sometimes even a fighter has to learn
how to fight
fighting for real and fighting for a
camera it's two different things
[Music]
welcome back canada has given the world
to sport some legendary contributions
like the game of basketball or the great
one and our next group of athletes
proves when it comes to winning it all
comes so naturally
it's a great feeling right now sprinting
all the way from scarborough yes andre
is definitely a national treasure with
six yes six olympic medals when you
think of the number
19.62 i mean when you saw that number
what was your reaction um i was just
really happy about winning i wasn't
thinking about the time i was happy that
i won the gold but of course yeah that's
running that fast i had broken my
national record the day before so
i knew i was capable of doing more so
when i saw the time i was like it was
great but i was just more happy that you
know i had finally won a gold medal so
that's what i was most proud of it's
great to be back and andre is always
giving back i love the kids so it's
really inspirational for me to be out
here and i'm inspiring the kids being
here today just shows that how much of
impact i can make
so definitely down the road i want to
have a foundation try to give back to my
community
you know no matter what i always love
that feeling of hitting the ball i love
that feeling of competing
so i always have those um emotions
running through me and she's running
through our minds too yeah we've always
had heart eyes for jeannie bouchard are
you serious
hashtag smile yeah every single post i
put hashtags i feel like people smile
after they read smiles they're like wow
who's this dork
a dork no way a 10 is darling the
montreal native became the first
canadian-born player to reach the final
of a grand slam tournament in singles
not to mention a court load of more
accolades and to top it off her social
game is on point she's hilarious how
many sauce does it take
to have kim k boos
i'm in love with what i do for a living
that's where it is right now hi my name
is jose
you probably know me as the mixed
martial artist we certainly do but after
26 ufc wins one of the greatest fighters
in history hangs up his belts now that i
retire i really take that as a full-time
job and it's been two years two years
that i
every week i'm having an acting class
and i really focus on this yes instead
of fighting in the ring he's fighting on
screen reprising his role in captain
america in the tv series the falcon and
the winter soldier and we are loving it
fighting for real and fighting for a
camera it's two different things
[Music]
welcome back now before we go we
couldn't forget canada's pop punk
princess i know we can from let go to
love sucks 20 years later we're still
loving every levine
i'm having the time of my life i love
this record because it has tons of
energy
and like i just didn't hold back i just
went for it
you know i don't use the word icon a lot
but i think that works with april
hundred percent
all right now i think the best way to
wrap up this special is to leave you
with avril's first hit great idea i hope
you enjoyed our crushing on canadian
special thank you for watching everybody
here's avril with complicated bye
[Music]
me frustrated
[Music]